well it appears that unity and
compromise we heard
those words a lot during the course of
the campaign apparently they're not the
priority anymore president joe biden and
democrats plowed ahead
with an almost two trillion dollar
coveted relief bill that's on top of the
four and a half that we've already
pushed through and they got zero support
from the gop on that they wanted to
compromise on a number of issues here
the president also took a swipe at
republicans for
not backing this very expensive plan if
i have to choose between getting help
right now to americans
who are hurting so badly and getting dr
bogged down in a monthly negotiation
or compromising on a bill that's that
that's up to the crisis
that's an easy choice what republicans
have proposed
is either to do nothing or not enough
over the fiscal restraint and the
concern for the deficits
moves like that from president biden
pleasing the far left
of his party politico reporting that
progressives have quote
learned to love the guy when they have
watched these early moves so far in the
first couple of weeks and senator
elizabeth warren
says that she is very impressed with the
economic action
that president biden is taking watch
this
joe biden ran on the most
progressive agenda ever and now
he is meeting the moment and we need to
continue to hold
everyone accountable to the promises
that have been made
it's a good time
it is a good time jesse it's a good time
um
so apparently you know uh
he ran as a moderate but that was in his
personal capacity apparently over the
course of the election
but now he is governing in a a very very
different way
i may look naive martha but i'm not
politicians lie
they run as uniters and they govern as
dividers
joe biden maybe was a moderate when he
was backslapping
segregationist senators in the 70s and
80s
that washington is long gone and
partisan he was like that as vp for
barack obama
he didn't ever reach across the aisle
then they did scorched earth
and to be honest with you they have the
numbers and if you have the numbers in
washington you run up the score
and they're going to run up the score
and they're going to nuke whatever they
want through
republicans aren't going to be able to
do anything about it until they take
back the house and the senate
if you thought that joe is a moderate
look who's kissing him
his you know what it's liz warren bernie
sanders and aoc
the socialists are now at the white
house they're smoking a peace pipe
and apparently life is good that doesn't
mean life is good for us when life is
good for them
but life is good for them for now and i
stress for now
so uh juan let me go to you on that you
know you have often
indicated that joe biden is more of a
moderate
that is not at all the picture that
we're seeing so far he's not willing to
work with the gop on anything and
you know elections have consequences as
everybody loves to say um
so you know moderation be damned is that
is that okay with you
you know i'm just puzzled by that
picture martha because i think i just
saw
was it this week that there were 10
republicans at the white house
talking with joe biden they came out and
they said to the reporters
it was a great meeting we're willing to
deal with this man
he understands what we are what we need
and what we're proposing
so i don't see that it's that it got him
nowhere that got them absolutely nowhere
that was just for show
they got nowhere well okay i'm just
saying i'm just saying
they had a meeting and i think that it
might go somewhere because what i've
heard from biden
as well as from the republicans is
there's a potential for this to be a
bipartisan bill
everything is being put in place for the
democrats to say if we have the votes if
necessary to do it
unilaterally but i think people still
have some hopes that there will be some
cooperation
but my bigger point to you is this i
think the american people need help
right now we had a jobs report today
uh you know that was dismal it's been
the third month
where the jobs report has not been good
martha and
you know i just think you have to have a
sense of urgency about getting something
done getting help out to people right
now and the gop
has lacked that urgency and for the
democrats perspective you look back at
bill clinton and i believe that was 93
barack obama in 09 when they were
dealing with recessions
and trying to get republicans to help
republicans then were oh yeah well we'll
come along what about this what about
that
and there's i just said come on i mean
last summer the president wanted
no doubt that's not true that's not true
last summer
the president wanted a too close to two
trillion dollar bill
nancy pelosi walked away they would do
nothing until after the election so
don't tell me that they didn't want to
do something because it's perfectly
clear
that they absolutely didn't want to do
something but i want to get to degan
real quick and to greg as well no that
is true they didn't want to do it
mcconnell was the one that wouldn't hold
a vote
that's a lie that's a lie that's a lie
that's a lie
because no i'm going to stop you right
there that's not what happened
on more than on two occasions the
democrats refused to vote for even
debate
on stimulus in the fall because again
they were standing atop the suffering of
americans trying to win an election
and not give donald trump a win and that
is absolutely true
yes it is you can fact-check me because
guess what
the record shows that democrats in the
house passed a bill
i believe it was in may or june and the
senate wouldn't act
which had a tax cut for wealthy people
in blue states
and that's exactly what this 2 trillion
from
from joe biden is it is a rather than
telling these blue states to open up
that's how you save jobs they're giving
them handouts
for um to liberal governors and
officials who don't know how to do math
who've run their economies into the
ground this is pure suck-up budding
and here's the biggest problem there is
most
a much of the 900 billion stimulus and
the stimulus from the fall
has gone unspent you've got two trillion
dollars in excess savings among
individuals because they haven't had
anywhere to spend it they don't need
two trillion dollars more into this
economy because you know what happens
runaway inflation like the 70s the
economy
suck then including the outfits yeah
well we've never flooded the market with
money like we are now greg and there's a
lot of economists who think that we're
going to end up in a situation where we
do have
inflation um you know one way to get the
economy going is to to get
things open which we haven't really
heard that much about from joe biden i
think we've lost the
the idea of what money is right now now
that we're dealing with trillions and
but i think the bigger issue here i mean
we
wouldn't when prior to the election we
must have done a half a dozen segments
where juan did say that joe biden was a
moderate and that's why he was so
popular was that he was the most
moderate
and and we all heard it but we work in
tv
and we all knew that's why we kept
saying it's a trojan horse
it's a trojan horse he's gonna once he
gets there he's gonna change
so we all kind of understood it it's the
american people that got screwed
this was purely a bait and switch joe is
a hollowed out
vessel for the left that's why he got
the job
he's a pez dispenser pumping out
left wing candy every single day it's a
nice new
shiny piece of candy for the left and
the left are like the grifter relatives
of a senile
uncle who takes him to the to the atm to
withdraw
money every friday and he has no idea
what's going on
we we all got screwed and it's bigger
i have to say it's got a longer term
consequence than just covet
you're going to talk about things that
are going to change the fabric of
america in terms of identity politics
racial politics taxation
um uh burdens on the economy uh student
debt which we're going to talk about
climate uh climate politics all these
things
are going to be coming from a very very
far left perspective
which is in which is being placed inside
through joe
and pumped out of his mouth and i would
ask everybody
to go to time.com and read the secret
history of the shadow
campaign that saved the 2020 election
it's gonna blow your mind because they
are
boasting they are the left are boasting
how they got this
done they're not even hiding it anymore
all right coming up democrats
demand